[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys wels
heute möchte ich ein experiment machen
ein experiment auch schon gute
fortschritte experiment und zwar lieben
wir windbeutel die werden ja aus einem
brunch teig hergestellt
wir lieben erklärt die werden ja auch
aus einem brand hergestellt und heute
habe ich mir gedacht machen wir einen
eklat
aber als rolle also sozusagen eine
notizen erklärt und dafür braucht ihr
wirklich nur ganz wenige zutaten und ich
glaube erklär schmeckt jedem es wird
auch liebes knochen genannt warum auch
immer
manchmal wird es gefüllt mit
vanillecreme oder auch mit einer show
buch reden wir machen seit ganz
klassisch mit einer sahne creme und
außen rum kommt an einer schokocreme ich
glaube damit kann ich hier die mädels
und jungs wirklich begeistern für den
brand teig nämlich 60 gramm butter 250
gramm wasser 200 gramm mehl eine prise
salz etwas wandel extrakt und vier bis
fünf eier und zuerst nimmt jetzt die
zutaten und geht mal richtung herz denn
ihr braucht zuerst mal einen topf nehmt
ihr einfach einen topf der groß genug
ist da kommt das wasser rein dann die
butter und das salz und die zutaten
die müssen jetzt einmal aufkochen und
der teig heißt brandtag weil er eben am
tropf den topf vom herd abgebrannt wird
also nicht angebracht wird sondern
abgebrannt und das bewirkt dann dass der
teig später schön aufgeht und der teig
eben auch die luft in sich speichern
ich glaube ein bisschen zu viel theorie
deswegen die info reicht ja hast du
wirklich jetzt am herd schön abbrennen
jetzt kocht das wasser das letzte stück
butter schmilzt gerade und jetzt gebt
ihr das mehl in einem schwung dazu jetzt
ordentlich rühren damit so ein richtig
toller großer trägt prozent steht jetzt
einfach so ein bis zwei minuten weiter
rühren und den teig schön abbrennen und
boden hier bildet sich dann ein weißer
belag und daran erkennt ihr dann dass er
gut ist
wenn ihr übrigens die kenwood cooking
chef habt die gummi dann können wir das
einfach darin machen dann spart ihr euch
nämlich das rühren ist übernimmt dann
die küchenmaschine für euch also am herd
kochen hannovers und dann füllt ihr den
teig einfach um eine große schale da
könnt ihr jetzt auch gerne die
küchenmaschine nehmen und den topf den
reinigt er jetzt noch nicht lass dir
einfach abkühlen denn der ball lag hier
am boden der kommt dann von alleine raus
also das stand wie so eine art brot
effekt ist nicht wegschmeißen ihr soll
das wirklich mal probieren einfach
abkühlen lassen und dann löst sich das
wie so eine art knusper brot und damit
hier ist der teig abkühlt drücke ich
ihnen hier so ein bisschen an den rand
so denn so ein flop skills nicht so
schnell abbiege und flacher teig so ein
bisschen öffnen 23 minuten abkühlen
lassen und dann geht es gleich weiter
mit den eiern
guck mal ich hab nix dran gemacht und
das kloster brot lässt sich von ganz
alleine
ich habe es mal nach freunden gezeigt
und dann hat's exakter hätte das früher
gewusst hätte ich auch immer gegessen
und nicht weggespült kinder spricht
jetzt und jetzt gebe ich hier war ein
extrakt dazu und ich nehme jetzt ein
android gerät hat wahrscheinlich auch
jeder von euch zu hause
ihr könnt aber auch den kochlöffel
nehmen also den bug klasse dauert nur
ein bisschen und es erfordert
kraft in den armen jetzt gibt ihr einen
nach dem anderen dazu das erste ei das
sieht immer aus als wird sich die massen
ii verbinden aber bleibt schlimm dran
und ich nehme jetzt erstmal nur vier es
kann aber auch sein dass ich fünf
braucht man je nachdem wie groß eben
auch die eier sind jetzt einfach schön
rühren und dann ist nächste eine tote
[Musik]
nach vier sieht derzeit so aus als er
ist wirklich noch viel zu fest denn am
brandtag der muss schöne spitzen zähnen
und glänzen darf aber auch nicht so sehr
verflüssigt werden durch den 1
deswegen gebe ich jetzt noch eins dazu
das müsste dann genug sein
[Musik]
das ist zum teil bei dem es sich nicht
lohnt davison abzuschrecken
weil einfach noch nicht so gut schmeckt
also sieht er jetzt aus schön glänzend
ja der ist perfekt okay das mache ich
jetzt auch zum ersten mal also hab ich
das jetzt mit euch hier aus crivitz
ihrem ein backblech eine back folie die
nehme ich ganz gerne weil ich sie
einfach mehrfach verwenden kann und
nicht wegschmeißen muss so eine dauer
back folie und jetzt gebe ich den brand
tag hier drauf daraus könnte tier jetzt
auch windbeutel herstellen oder erklärt
machen
der mann ist eine erklärung verteilen
schon mal grob mit dem tragschrauber
einfach zu einem großen rechteck
[Musik]
und hier achtet jetzt darauf dass er
gleichmäßig verteilt ist damit alle
stellen auch gleichzeitig gar werden
und da ist jetzt hier schön auf blech
größe so das hat man bei uns hier so
gesagt und es bei euch auch gesagt okay
einigen guckt schon so war ihr sagt man
das nicht bei uns hier oder wie jetzt
das gemacht und fertig
den rest mache ich jetzt einfach mit der
hand ein bisschen wasser an die hände
frank bestreite ich sowieso immer mit
wasser vor dem backen und jetzt einfach
nur so drüber
und so kommt die brandtag platte die
eclair platte in den backofen und wird
gebacken während der bauzeit auf keinen
fall den backofen öffnen ansonsten geht
der teig zwar schön aus aber dann felder
zusammen deswegen wirklich die backzeit
auch beachten lieber ne minute zu lang
backen als zu kurz und ihm der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die
kamaz herstellen also die
schokoladencreme und jetzt erstmal auf
händler
[Musik]
für die kanal verwende ich jetzt 150
gramm sahne 200 bitterschokolade und
dann verfalle ich sie noch hier mit
diesem kaffeearoma das erste mal ganz
praktisch vor allem rechts ganz gut und
ihr könnt einfach kaffeegeschmack
reinbringen ohne kaffee zu verwenden und
das riecht ein bisschen nach
karamellisiertem kaffee also echt lecker
ihr könnt aber auch echten kaffee dazu
geben oder auch in anderen geschmack für
rom zum beispiel oder kirschwasser oder
was auch immer euch einfällt bei der
gala steht könnt ihr euch ganz toll
verfeinern
jetzt wird einfach nur die sahne
aufgekocht und dann kommt die schokolade
dazu und da rate ich euch auch wirklich
zu zarter schokolade
ich nehme sogar herren schokolade die
hat 60 kakaoanteil und die schmeckt
einfach mega schokoladig ist nicht ganz
so süß wie vollmilch schokolade und man
hat einfach diesen schoko geschmack und
sobald die sein und an kopf den herd
ausschalten
die schokolade dazu den puck dann immer
dass alle schokostückchen mit der sahne
bedeckt sind dann rühren
unser wald die schokolade geschmolzen
ist lasse ich die ganz abgedeckt
abkühlen nicht im kühlschrank sondern
bei raumtemperatur damit sehr schön
streichfähig wird
so sieht die platte jetzt aus ist auch
völlig normal dass sie hügelig ist
seinem brand teig und ich ziehe sie
jetzt direkt vom heißen blech runter auf
dem kaltes blech text mit einem tuch ab
und lasse jetzt vollständig erkalten bis
dahin ist die garage auch bereit und
dann geht es gleich weiter mit dem
füllen
die transtec platte ist abgekühlt
danach steht auch schon kalt jetzt kommt
die sahne creme dran da mache ich jetzt
einfach eine ganz normale geschlagene
sahne
ich nehme also etwas sahne wandel
extrakt puderzucker und seiner partei
jetzt kommt die kalte sahne hier in eine
große rührschüssel der puderzucker kommt
dazu finden immer einen weg von mir ab
oder zucker gesagt hat etwas von elektra
cd- und mit seiner tat schlag ich dann
die creme steif
[Musik]
hattet ihr löst sich echt ganz gut von
der bak folie ab ich habe jetzt hier die
erhöhungen aber ihr seht schon so
richtig schön luftig das heißt ich kann
dir gleich einfach ein bisschen flach
drücken
das heißt hier kommt jetzt die sahne
drauf
[Musik]
ok ich probier das jetzt glaube ich
fange an mich hier aufzuholen
ich hab ich mal hier gemacht die ränder
sind halt so ein bisschen knusprig
deswegen könnt ihr die für die so ein
bisschen ein klickt dann geht es um mein
gott ist das mal regel sind rolle
ich hab dir ausgesuchte platte die post
gar nicht die kommt jetzt ganz kurz in
den kühlschrank und dann kommt da die
schokocreme drauf und dann bin ich mal
gespannt darauf ist ein echt mega locker
schlagt jetzt so ein
gerade für so ein halbe stunde ungefähr
ihr könnt auch kurz ins gefrierfach
stellen und dann wird der chor jetzt
kommt die kamera die streit ist jetzt
hier drauf
[Musik]
das ist jetzt die erste portion garagen
jetzt kommt sie in den kühlschrank
ich werde jetzt noch mal die gleiche
menge an ghanas herstellen weil die
jetzt nicht komplett gereicht hat ist
aber gar nicht schlimm
also wenn es euch so schon optisch
reicht können wir sie gerne so lassen
und mit kakao bestreuen
ich mache es aber nochmal die ghana
damit ich eine schöne sprachen optik
noch machen kann
aber jetzt die erste geschichte mal im
kühlschrank fest werden lassen und damit
der zweiten schicht dekorieren schoko
schießt du dir diese football videos wo
wir so schokolade und dann bevor
deshalb würde ich mich gerade mit einem
leichten tropfen das abschluss ist im
hintergrund fährt jetzt fällt ist mit
anna eine schöne und gleichmäßige
oberfläche machen
ich meine die rolle kriegt ja auch gar
nicht gleich weiß nicht also muss nicht
das zu zeigen und dann stelle ich sie
jetzt kurz in den kühlschrank damit noch
etwas anziehen kann
und dann probieren wir sogleich die
rolle
na ja es ist schon spät am abend am
nachmittag
ja ich sag einfach nichts mehr
[Musik]
für die optik habe ich jetzt hier noch
gefriergetrocknete himbeeren darüber
gebrütet
aber ich glaube auch dass sie
geschmacklich sehr gut dazu passen
morand bitte komm her ich bin hier für
die erklärung was willst du es dann halt
erklärt
das ist eine erklärung ist was mir auch
cool aussieht wenn du zum beispiel
physalis nimmst du mich für alles
anrichten tust mir schon auch cool aus
so lebt für seine rechte lust drauf weiß
das gibt es gratis
es wird zu sagen wie es ähnlich doch
werde es in meinem garten stehen stehen
wir manche eltern nicht den eigentlich
können uns auch vom strauch wieder
machen so lässt sich echt gut schneiden
die hwg den kameraden der graduierung
ist immer so dass jetzt ein brand am
brandtag habe ich zum ersten mal gemacht
brandtag und dann woher du bist echt
corinna visser
ich hatte übrigens heute denn freuen
wenn wir dazu mir gesagt hat er mal die
ersten monats fünf minuten angeschaut
einzigen und es hat sich grundsätzlich
verändert
jetzt weiß ich auch schneller geworden
ja jetzt was im land halt ist und ich
weiß was nicht anders ist und wie eine
galaxie macht und deine frau erfüllt den
jeden wunsch
also ich meine so ein tortenstück ist
halt schon groß ist und muss wie zwei
erklärt zusammen ganz großen typ bist
richtig mächtig ja aber es ist halt eine
torte
ja das ist richtig mächtiges hi hat sich
jetzt sein tipp wie die nicht alleine
ist ja das ist mein thema auf und
erkläre nennt man ja auch liebes knochen
hatte sich gesagt das ist doch das steht
bei wikipedia sogar darin besteht in
jedem content auf jedem kontinent was du
jetzt noch was ganz anderes machen
es ist einfach nur ein teil brannte
schokolade drüber als er mächtig ist mit
der doppelten portion danach aber ich
finde wir nur die einfache portierung
gemacht ist die optik noch nicht so mega
du bist noch immer die ghanas nehmen und
dann das innere ist was so an sich von
gut geht solltet ihr mal ausprobieren
und die himbeeren passen
für sage es passt auch noch mal ich habe
übrigens kaffeearoma in die garage ich
hab ich ja noch ein bisschen mehr rein
noch habe ich vor schulbeginn dafür dass
sie mächtig findet dann aber mächtig
rein ja ich wollte dann richtig
reinhauen
denn nicht alle rechte liegen
macht's besser
das rezept findet ihr wie immer in der
app oder auch sehr großes problem also
bis zum nächsten mal
und ich mache es noch die fotos
[Musik]
das war ganz schön mächtig also
personen haushalt ist das ding nicht
gemacht viel spaß dass der letzte liebe
ist noch ein wenig für dich gemacht
ok ja keiner des knochenmarks